- All right everybody,
our first guest is one of our favorites,
one of my personal favorites.
You can see him in Stargirl,
and on The CW and in Crime
Scene Kitchen on Fox.
He's a talented actor,
and a brilliant host,
and a super rad dad.
Please welcome, Joel McHale.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
- Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- I lo-
- Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
- I lo-, I, I can't hug you yet.
- Oh, okay.
- Cause of Covid. I can do that.
- How 'bout one of these?
- How 'bout this? Oh!
- Oh! See, got you.
(Kelly laughs)
- Dad joke.
- What's gonna happen?
(Kelly laughs)
- Wait.
- Hello rad dads.
- What's in the
- Rad dads.
(audience cheers)
- Hello, rad dads. What?
- Are you?
- I am, uh
- Are you holding dead fish?
- No, I'm very nauseous.
- What?
- And so I was like, the
show must go on Kelly.
- Dead fish in a bucket
- Uh yeah I brought
some dead fish for you.
- Okay.
- I know you're a big fan of Montana.
- It' a little, I am.
- The rivers where you fish there.
- I'm a fan of live things too.
- Like what?
- Like that they're alive, that they're
- All right. Well, I brought
some live things with me.
- Okay. So can we see the
animals that you brought?
I wanna see the animals.
- Uh no, those are my kids.
- What?
- Yeah, I care, but I want
- Father of the year.
- I want you to notice that
I put holes in the box.
So, I'm not an animal.
(crowd cheers)
- Yeah, rad dads. Thank you, rad dad.
- Wait, I wanna see.
- All right, let's, yeah.
Let's see what it is.
- Okay, okay.
- Let's, it'll be a surprise.
Are we taking the box off?
- I don't know. Are we?
- All right.
- No
- Yeah, let's do it.
- No, we're not.
- We're not.
- I'm gonna on this side.
- Well there's people
for that that are wearing
- Oh there's gonna, oh thank you.
- The Kelly Clarkson Show. Look at that.
- You're very tall
- Oh yeah. Here you guys go.
Yeah. Hey, what's up guys?
- Oh my God!
- Yeah. There you go. All right. These
- Wait, can I feed?
- These are Bald Eagles, and, uh
(Kelly laughs)
- Can I feed?
- Oh, there you go.
- Hi.
- There you go guys. Yeah. This is uh
- Oh my God, you brought penguins!
- Squishy and Tuck.
Yeah. These are my own.
Uh, I live in studio city.
So that, they're indigenous.
- You want this one, buddy? Ope, sorry!
- They grow
- Ope, sorry!
- What the, oh, you're not hungry guys?
Tushy. I mean, Tuck, Squishy.
Didn't you want one?
Oh, they're too, you know what?
They're fascinated by the rad dads.
- They're fascinated.
- Uh.
- That's so, hey wait
- These are
- This is perfect for rad dads.
So wait, I, I aren't like penguins,
I feel like I've watched
this on Discovery Channel.
Aren't like the father's great fathers?
- Let's not promote other networks, okay?
- No, no, no.
- I know you've syndicated. I'm kidding.
- No, I've, I've
(Kelly laughs)
- No, I've seen it.
Like, I think they share the duties,
like moms and dads, penguins.
- Yes. They, um, they sit on the eggs
just as much as mom does.
- Exactly.
- And, uh, I did the same thing.
I sat on my wife's womb for, uh,
(Kelly laughs)
- Which uh turned out
was a terrible mistake.
They're not as hungry uh, as usual. Hey.
- They're not hungry.
- You know
- So what
usually I get them,
uh, like a baked perch,
and they're like,
- What is this?
- This is disgusting. This is raw fish.
(Kelly laughs)